IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
>> WE HAVE PAT FALLON FROM TEXAS
WITH US.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF
YOUR THANKSGIVING WEEKEND TO
JOIN US TO TALK WITH US ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC AND
CRITICAL TO YOUR STATE.
LET'S START WITH YOUR THOUGHTS,
THE BACK AND FORTH.
MCCARTHY CALLING FOR MAYOKAS TO
STEP DOWN OR FACE IMPEACHMENT
AND DHS SAYING IT ISN'T
HAPPENING.
>> THEY SAID HE INHERISTED THIS
PROBLEM.
LET'S LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AND
DATA.
THIS APRIL THERE WAS THE WORST
MONTH.
IN MAY IT WAS 241,000 ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS, 930% WORSE
THAN WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE.
BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE
THE ISSUE TEN TIMES WORSE.
WE HAVE HAD EIGHT MONTHS IN A
ROW OF OVER 200,000 ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS.
WHAT HIS POLICIES HAVE GONE IS
MADE EVERY STATE A BORDER STATE.
>> ONE OF THE OTHER BIG ISSUES
WE'RE WATCHING ONGOING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN ORDERED
TO STOP USING TITLE 42 SLATED TO
END DECEMBER 31ST TO TURN AWAY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS RELATED TO
HEALTH POLICY.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THE ONGOING
CRISIS IS ABOUT TO GET FAR
WORSE?
>> YES, YOU TOOK THE WORDS OUT
OF MY MOUTH.
IT IS A CATASTROPHE AS GONZALEZ
SAID.
LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
THE ILLEGAL NARCOTICS?
MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS ARE
CONTROLLING THE BORST.
WE LOST SO MANY AMERICANS TO
OPIOID OVERDOSES.
80,000 TO -- WE LOST 293
AMERICANS A DAY.
IN WORLD WAR II WE LOST 297 A
DAY.
WARFARE WAGED BY THE CHINESE
COMMUNISTS, WE HAVE TO CHANGE
COURSE.
>> YOU ARE BRINGING ATTENTION TO
THIS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
CHRISTINA COLEMAN SHOWING US THE
BUSES OF MIGRANTS ARRIVING IN
PENNSYLVANIA TODAY.
NOW REPUBLICAN ATTORNEYS GENERAL
FROM 15 G.O.P.-LED STATES ARE
FIGHTING TO KEEP TITLE 42.
ALASKA, KANSAS, WEST VIRGINIA
HAVE SUBMITTED A MOTION TO THE
JUDGE TO INTERVENE.
THEY ARGUE IF TITLE 42 IS
TERMINATED THERE WILL BE
INCREASED RELEASE OF ALIENS AND
FLOW TO OTHER STATES.
WE'RE SEEING BUSES GOING AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND A FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON THE STATES THAT WILL
BE HOSTING THEM.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
DO THE A.G.s HAVE A CASE AND A
CHANCE OF SUCCEEDING?
>> I CERTAINLY HOPE SO BECAUSE
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN 5 MILLION
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS WHEN
YOU CONSIDER AND COUNT THE
ENCOUNTERS WE'VE HAD AND KNOWN
GOTAWAYS UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S A HUGE AMOUNT.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS CAN
ONLY HANDLE UP TO 5,000 ILLEGAL
CROSSERS A DAY.
WE'RE ALREADY LOOKING AT TWICE
THAT AND IF TITLE 42 -- IF TITLE
42 GOES AWAY, THEN WE ARE
LOOKING AT A FLOOD THAT WILL BE
UNSTOPPABLE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION REFUSES TO
INSTITUTE THE WAIT IN MEXICO
POLICY WHICH PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID.
IF YOU ARE CLAIMING ASYLUM YOU
HAVE TO WAIT IN MEXICO WHILE WE
ADJUDICATE YOUR CASE.
>> KEVIN MCCARTHY IS TRYING TO
WALK THIS PATH TO BECOME SPEAKER
FACING A FEW BUMPS IN THE ROAD.
A FIVE LAWMAKER HAS ANNOUNCED
OPPOSITION JOINING SOME OTHER
MORE VOCAL OPPONENTS TO THAT.
IF THE CURRENT MARGINS HOLD,
REPUBLICANS ONLY HAVE ABOUT A
FOUR-VOTE MAJORITY.
THAT'S PRETTY TIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT MEANS FOR
KEVIN MCCARTHY AS HE AIMS FOR
THIS ASCENT?
>> THE RULES STATE WE HAVE
NOMINEES AND OUR OWN INTERNAL
DEBATES, DISCUSSIONS AND THAT WE
VOTE.
KEVIN MCCARTHY WON THE VOTE
188-31.
HE IS NOW OUR NOMINEE.
I DON'T WANT THE DEMOCRATS TO
HAVE ANY SAY WHATSOEVER IN WHO
THE NEXT SPEAKER IS.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY SAY WHEN
NANCY PELOSI WAS ELECTED.
SO TIME WILL TELL BUT KEVIN
MCCARTHY IS THE ONE.
WE HAVE THE MAJORITY NOW AND LED
US TO THAT MAJORITY AND ALSO
WENT AROUND THE COUNTRY FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS RAISING HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS FOR CANDIDATES TO
INSURE WE COULD RETIRE NANCY
PELOSI ONCE AND FOR ALL.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE
TIGHT MARGINS?
>> SURE.
MOLLY, IF WE HAD DONE 3% BETTER
WE WOULD HAVE HAD 24 MORE REPS.
THE RED WAVE ALMOST HIT.
NOT QUITE.
WE WOULD HAVE 245.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'LL HAVE 222.
EVERY VOTE, IF WE LOSE FIVE WE
DON'T WIN.
WE HAVE TO REALLY UNITE AND HOLD
TOGETHER THE CONFERENCE.
>> DO YOU THINK IT MEANS WE'LL
SEE A LOT OF POWER IN SOME OF
THE MORE MODERATE MEMBERS OF
YOUR PARTY?
>> I HOPE THAT THE CONSERVATIVES
RULE THE DAY.
I HAVE TALKED TO KEVIN MCCARTHY
AND SO HAVE OTHERS WE NEED TO
PAINT BOLD COLORS NOT SOFT
PASTELS.
TAKE A BOOK OUT OF RONALD REAGAN
AND DONALD TRUMP AND REALLY
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE THAT GOT US
HERE AND DO WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> RED WAVE OR NOT IT WILL BE
INTERESTING.
APPRECIATE YOUR INSIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUC